hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba look
who it is
you have no idea no idea it's Sharon hi
I'm a huge fan of evil attacks that's
why I'm here I met Jarrod at Collider
can I say where you're where you're
first known from yeah I was on The
Bachelorette and it's on The
Bachelorette my ego has not gone down at
all sitting next to this guy are you
kiddin me like I'm a huge fan of you
guys are you joking I wish that I had
your looks and your personality in your
brain I don't know you have a girlfriend
I'm single yeah boy I need a girl for
and I made sure to kick her out before
he showed yes we met at Collider but
come talking this guy he really knows
his film he was not a point Collider
movie talk about screening junkies like
TV fights I thought that was cool
because I don't know two people who have
competed on the bachelor or bachelorette
can actually talk a lot about films so
good for you man thanks but luckily
enough I was able to get connected like
from being on The Bachelor that's how I
was able yeah that's with Collider cuz
like there's some people that work a
Collider that our former producers on
the show which worked out perfectly
because I've been watching Collider
since AMC and I've been watching you
guys and Jeremy Jones and screen junkies
and like everything that you guys watch
obviously so you're a geek and really
good-looking that's fair that's yeah I
literally put this white tee on you're
wearing a Superman shirt on a black
panther video Oh way to go buddy we're
all superheroes here well this clip from
ellentube which I just saw sent you is
on Ellen and now you've upgraded your my
good job really climbing the ladder
there's clips called cars chase all
right let's check it out and let's talk
some black pants there's not wearing his
mask
and that looks real
[Music]
Oh such a cool power that's pretty
badass
I'm excited for Black Panthers I didn't
realize what the suit can do I didn't
know I don't know much about Black
Panther that's the thing racist that's
where I get out that was really cool
when he's getting hit by bullets but
that's absorbing energy which a lot of
them do that card exploit yeah I mean
like uses the energy to make it like an
electric magnetic pulse thing because it
explode with an explosion yeah there's
like an energy force field yeah we sound
like we know what we're talking about I
didn't know much about Black Panther
going into civil war either and yeah I
was a little nervous and then he ended
up being one of the best parts of the
movie
and so now I'm super pumped full by
Panther especially that ryan coogler
director and it's the highest like
pre-sold movie ever I'm hearing that
it's getting more it got more pre-sales
than civil war yeah which is kind of
shocking to me it's really shocking I
don't feel like Black Panthers as
well-known as a lot of these other
superheroes I agree there's something
about this film that I feel like a lot
of people are very much gravitated
towards and it's cool to see like a
first black Superman oh there was blade
but in the MCU blade is awesome but
obviously the bit like the first lead
black superhero in the MCU yeah the
marketing campaign is really good it's
definitely for a younger generation yeah
like between the music the cast it's for
everybody but it's specifically for like
that age demographic between yeah 24 and
36 and you bring up a good point about
the cast because that's the other thing
too that I feel that makes us really
special is that it's not that's just I
was like this one black superhero it has
a hole in Samba love a variety of
different characters that are all black
characters yeah it gets me really
excited when people behind the scenes
are also african-american yeah so this
movie's gonna be really sick and just it
was cool to see it just a full clip yeah
well clip but us at least like a clip
from the movie because what we see is
trailer so far all I've seen is trailer
yeah and to see how it all plays out
it's like it's smooth action sequences
the music too a lot of times MCU films
get a little flack for the lack of music
it's desert
here I was hearing the music I was like
we say actually sounds pretty sweet in
this clip I think the music is gonna be
awesome this movie it's interesting even
like the color scheme is interesting in
this clip because everything is kind of
have like a purple tinge to it
even as yeah like when he absorbs the
energy it has this purple it looks like
almost electricity yeah and then the
bridge it's purple and blue and it has
bright vibrant colors that's a good eye
right here more than just a pretty face
and it also jumped out to me that the
mast like when he was first running he
didn't have his mask on and then he did
a backflip and then the mast like
generally on his face I think in civil
war he takes it off it he does right do
myself
warmer on it so this is obviously a
difference yeah I know he gets a new
suit in this one yeah it's an updated
suit I feel like this film will have a
lot of distinct standalone things about
this film I agree it's in the look the
music and the overall style and I we got
like three MCU movies a year oftentimes
it's easy to forget the distinctness of
a certain film I agree and I feel like
this one will really stand out we'll
remember what specifically makes it this
thing I agree and I love what the MCU is
doing they come out with Thor Ragnarok
which is like pretty much a comedy and
then they're coming out with Black
Panther which feels like a complete
departure of what the MCU has been doing
it's like its own movie right yeah you
hire a guy like Ryan Coogler with the
music and the marketing campaign like we
talked about before it feels very
detached yeah see you I feel like just
Marvel's killing it they're just able to
hire the right talent they make good
movies and this is gonna be no different
I feel like people [ __ ] a lot about
Marvel because there's a large influx of
Marvel throughout the year but I think
it's historically monumental what
they've done in cinema oh I don't think
there's any question about and and I
think it's amazing what they've
accomplished I don't ever really
complain about too much more below cuz I
think it's freakin fantastic while you
can still dish out great movies
consistently I think people say that
about Marvel because when somebody gets
to a certain level of success like
people want to see that tear torn down
them to a certain set to further that
point more the fact that DC is not
holding its own you can't help but
compare the two obviously yeah and so
the fact that DC is kind of failing in
Marvel's succeeding so well people like
I think when they tear down Marvel maybe
in the back of their head they're like
because DC's not good and they're trying
defendant yeah well they established a
cinematic universe and everything on it
and it's just not gonna end even when
Chris Evans retires and Robert Downey
jr. retires from their suits like
they're just Black Panther here we go
his first movie like there's probably
gonna be three Black Panthers in ya be
in the Avengers and have you know
Avengers infinity war Avengers for like
Black Panthers gonna be there ant-man is
getting a movie this summer and it's
non-stop man it's unbelievable it's cool
to be excited for the standalone film
and also be like oh yeah did you were to
get your presale tickets for Black
Panther or did you I haven't but I'm
going to you know it's probably shared
sure it's not like it's selling I got
four tickets at the very front row Wow I
have a big but it was a good you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification Bell on YouTube Jared
you can follow him on Twitter link in
the description box follow him on
Instagram you can find shirtless photos
with him there I like only those photos
shirt on shirtless as many as possible
he should do more of those I don't know
why you don't I need something to keep
my girlfriend satisfied I have too much
ham which has some like Austin Powers do
you really I have here my chest yeah I'm
sharing my chest yeah it's cuz we're
real men yeah at the real rejects yeah
[Applause]